[Music]
we have questions that were presubmit
and then we have questions that are
coming in on the live feed and I will do
my best to answer a whole bunch of both
so why don't we dive in the first
question I'll answer is from uh the live
this is from Zahir are you actively
taking any actions to reduce your carbon
footprint yes I am there are certainly a
number of different steps you can take
in terms of funding new technologies a
lot of my investing over the last I
would say 3 to four years has been in
various types of tech different products
and services that I think will overall
help people to reduce carbon footprint I
also donate money
monthly to different causes and
companies including charm industrial
which puts oil back underground people
can check that out at charm
industrial.com
and that I believe is
now funded through as it stands for me
teret I believe that is how I'm going
about doing this Terrace climate so
people can look at that as a means for
instance to hopefully offset some of the
carbon footprint of my travel and other
things I am intensely aware of
individual action but also the necessity
in a sense to number one not try to
consume our way out of this problem but
also simultaneously to recognize that we
do need better technology so it's a
combination of different
things all right this is a question from
the live feed what what classical career
are you in in a parallel reality this is
espanol 327 I would say neuroscientist
or marine biologist those were the two
professions that I most wanted to pursue
after age say 12 or 13 prior to that it
was comic book pencil so I would say
those are my classical careers as such
that might exist in some parallel set of
universes in the Multiverse on other
tracks that are running parallel to this
one let me go to the questions that were
presubmit and I will answer a number of
those and we'll bounce back and forth so
the next question is going to be from
lucus hey Tim you mentioned in an
interview that you allowed yourself to
live your life unoptimized are you still
living an unoptimized life I would say
that there's optimizing and de
optimizing happening simultaneously in
the sense that there are certain things
that I am optimizing to Define that
simply tweaking variables
to say improve certain outputs based on
the inputs right so looking for an
elegant refinement in so much as I might
approach something like aam's protocol
in the 4-Hour Body which I've ended up
following again roughly the same as it
was published in 2010 in the 4our body
this is a strength training and
resistance training program it's a very
minimalist but in the last 4 to 6 weeks
I've probably gained 10 to 15 pounds of
muscle and lost a decent amount of fat
in the process that's more diet
dependent than anything else the fat
lust side and that would be slow carb
diet but when you're approaching say
progressive resistance you want to
follow the metrics very closely have
some type of plan in advance so one
could argue that's optimizing but then
there's de optimizing and if you look at
my kitchen table and the books strewn
about including this one masterpieces of
fantasy art this is a Tashan book or
Tashan book Diane Hansen this is a gift
that
was put in front of me to my glee about
two weeks ago and I've been digesting
that very slowly as I have been
digesting different types of philosophy
and poetry which certainly I'm not
trying to speedread in any sense
whatsoever and went for a long
Meandering relatively unplanned hike
that is the path itself wasn't
predetermined with my dog Molly earlier
today so those would all be examples in
my mind of unoptimized living but they
go hand inand I don't think you can
really optimize any facet of your
life without perhaps strategically deop
op imizing or neglecting other aspects I
think it's beyond the reach of most
Mortals to optimize everything so it
becomes a question of trade-offs and
picking and
choosing question from Zane who is
someone you've been impressed with
lately that people may not know of and
why I would say one that comes to mind
is an oldie but a goodie this is a
Chinese photographer named fanho F an
last name ho o incredible photographer
director MTI hyphen it long since past
as I understand it but Fan's work is
truly spectacular in terms of the
composition of the images I think all
visual artists could learn a lot from
fanho so fanho would be what comes to
mind I'll do one more on the questions
that were presubmit from you all this is
from yavor do you use personal coaching
and how I have used a lot of personal
coaching throughout my life certainly
for sports for dance for let's just call
it Executive
coaching I would also check the box I've
worked with Jim Demmer at conscious.
that's the conscious leadership group
and I recommend their book the 15
commitments of conscious leadership I
believe it is which was initially
recommended to me if I'm recalling
correctly Dustin
moskovitz and there are many others that
I have used over time so the short
answer is yes in terms of how or why I
would say there are many different
breeds of Coach some focus on offering
strategic advice others act as
therapists in a sense ask you a certain
set of questions they tend to each have
their tool kits and they sort of elicit
different types of thinking by asking
questions that you would not be inclined
to ask yourself or perhaps respond to
differently when you're in a
conversation and then there are still
others who simp simply hold you
accountable or I should say not so
simply in all cases hold you accountable
and they have other types of value that
they offer but predominantly say for
someone in my position right now in this
chapter of my life as it's unfolding I
think that the greatest benefit is
having someone to stress test my
narratives and beliefs which are
sometimes so ingrained that you simply
see that as reality but to have someone
who can identify perhaps the beliefs
that you have't stress tested to really
break assumptions that need breaking or
rewrite narratives that need rewriting
number one number two to ask un
comfortable questions number three to
act as an accountability partner because
if you're at the top of the pyramid
organizationally speaking or if you're a
solar printer or anything like that even
if you're the CEO of a really large
company if you're at the top and
perhaps you don't have as much
accountability in certain respects as
you would like I think a coach can add a
lot of value in that capacity so those
are three of the questions I'm going to
jump back now to the live stream and see
what else we have going on here all
right this is a question from Reed if
I'm getting that
right how have you been working on your
good enough muscle good enough and good
enough is in quotation mark
and I suppose that's meant to underscore
my predisposition to being a
perfectionist and having some degree of
OCD to contend with the good enough
muscle
is actually I would say relatively easy
to exercise if you recognize you cannot
optimize all things as I mentioned
earlier and that it's a question of
trade-offs and much like some friends of
mine have said you should be or strive
to be world class in one or two things
and for the vast majority of other
things accept that good enough is plenty
good enough
and I would say that I'm trying to make
faster decisions if those decisions are
reversible or very low cost and then you
can sort
out the details often later so rather
than waiting or hoping or searching for
an additional 20% of information let's
just say you're at 60% and you think you
could make a better decision at 80 well
if it's very lowc cost or reversible or
both making a fast decision and
approaching it in more of a ready fire
aim sequence I think makes a lot of
sense so that's part of how I am
approaching things if that is helpful
all right somebody asked about the video
quality and the cam mic lighting details
of my current setup I have a Logitech
Brio webcam reasonably inexpensive I'd
say it's 70 or $80 connected to my
MacBook Pro this is an ATR I want to say
2100 microphone but it's probably the
later gen so an ATR maybe 2300 USBC mic
from Audio Technica this is probably
also 70 to 80 bucks and then in terms of
light there is no special lighting aside
from the ceiling lights and the natural
light coming through very large windows
in front of me so that is my fancy fancy
setup that fits in a backpack and often
travels with me in a backpack all right
this is a question from cranberry
leadership hi Tim if forced how much
your success can you directly attribute
to studying overseas direct attribution
is hard but I would say that certainly I
do not think I would be sitting here
today with
the trained ability I don't think it's
innate to ask questions about basic
assumptions to poke at conventional
wisdom in quotation marks and Convention
overall had I not spent time
abroad especially my first year abroad
as an exchange student in Japan given
how alien
and unlike the US Japan is in almost
every respect
so I think that that is has directly
contributed to my ability to operate in
the world in the way that I do and I'm
very grateful for that can we get a part
three with Todd mcfarling quite possibly
Todd is always good that's from Mobi and
I certainly wouldn't mind hopefully in
person I think that would be
better what would I add to 4our body if
I wrote it today from a name that I
cannot pronounce I would probably add a
chap chap on fasting and I would say
tools of Titans really was intended to
be almost an addendum
to the 4-Hour Work Week the 4-Hour Body
and the 4-Hour Chef in terms of say
healthy wealthy wise not necessarily in
that order but the fasting chapters and
also segments on mental health and
psychoemotional
health and psychedelics that were added
to tools of Titans I would say probably
with some tweaks and updates would have
been added to the 4our body or if I
revised it today those would be added
here's a question from antus if I'm
saying that correctly your vibe in this
place seems very intentional that is the
vibe behind me can you tell us more
about why you chose that Vibe I'll I'll
I'll leave the question of that yeah
this is a very rustic country feeling
and it's also a place that is intended
to be lived in so if you look at for
instance this wood behind me this is
going to be 20 30 40 years old maybe 50
years old the floors same and I've made
a few tweaks few upgrades here and there
but by and large this is intended to be
used possibly abused there's scratches
all over the table that I'm sitting at
with wine stains and so on from heavy
social use with friends and family and
this particular particular spot where
I'm spending time is intended to be
restful and easeful and part of that is
not looking like or being treated like a
museum also very sensitive to color
palette and natural light so there's a
lot of natural light here I love the
colors of fall so you'll notice the
backsplash behind the range has a very
Autumn themed palette to it and that is
also very much
deliberate all right this is a question
from Christina have you ever had
impostor syndrome with a podcast guest
if yes who and why so I wouldn't say
that I've had impostor
syndrome I would say that there times
when I have felt very nervous and
insecure and have been very worried
about stumbling and making mistakes I
think there are a few guests who come to
mind certainly my first episode with
Arnold Schwarzenegger that was 2015 and
that took a year a year and a half to
set up Jamie Fox similar that took a
year and a half or two years to set up
and I put incredible extended
preparation into both of those episodes
to give an example that may not be as
obvious as a as an A-list celebrity Ed
kmill who at the time I think was
president of Pixar he may have held some
other official title but Ed was the the
first person I had on the podcast who
was both high-profile and someone I had
never spoken with before so we had no
pre-existing Rapport no pre-existing
friendship and I was incredibly nervous
about that which is evidenced we may
have cleaned it up but as he spoke I was
so nervous every time he said
something I did what in Japanese I guess
would be iuchi which is like
confirmation
like so
this like someone who's hungry and
looking at a plate full of delicious hot
food drove people nuts and it was a
nervous tick which we we almost
certainly ended up editing out
significantly but I've never felt like
an impostor and I I'm not sure why that
is I know impostor syndrome and
that term get used a lot the the idea
that you're going to be found out is a
fraud or something like that but I've
always tried to be very transparent with
my weaknesses and where I am in the
learning curve with everyone including
my audience and I think that prevents
that or avoids it at least
so if I am on the stage telling people
that I have abnc weaknesses or that I
lack de andf experience and sometimes I
say that explicitly in my conversations
it's almost like preemptive body armor
in a sense not only against external
criticism but
self-criticism right I don't need any
additional fuel on the fire for negative
selft talk so that could be viewed as as
a way of sort of
bolstering my confidence in whatever
skills I might have or in the skills
that I'm
developing by laying it all on the table
if that makes any sense
all right why do I have a washing
machine in the kitchen that's a damn
fine question it was in here when I
bought the house I think it's ridiculous
but it doesn't really fit anywhere else
so that is why I have a washing machine
in the kitchen all
right I'll do a few more in the live
stream and then I'll go to the the
presubmit it it's from Joseph any plans
to go Backcountry skiing this winter
absolutely lots of plans to go back
country and side country skiing this
winter since that is one of my absolute
favorite activities so ski touring
probably on DPS touring skis which I
bought last season
and I am extremely excited could not be
more excited to get out and get amongst
it all right this is a question from
eron if you were to start your podcast
slbr over today what would you do
differently these these questions this
type of question is always challenging
to answer
because the time the times the
conditions have all changed and I have
changed what I would say is I started my
podcast almost 10 years ago this
upcoming April it'll be the 10th
anniversary of the podcast and when I
started I would
say podcasting was attractive for the
same reasons that Angel Investing were
attractive to me in say the 20072 2008
period and
a few of those ingredients are number
one it wasn't cutting cutting Cutting
Edge I wasn't the first person to
podcast there was a certain critical
mass of say a thousand true fans many
more certainly for shows like Rogan or
Nerdist or Mark Marin so there was a
there was a proof of concept already in
front of me I saw that something was
happening and gaining in momentum and
power with the Angel Investing very
similarly there were a lot of venture
capitalists a handful of angel investors
who were doing well there was this
burgeoning new species of investment
vehicle or person let's call it who were
deeming themselves micro VCS at the time
but it was otherwise pretty uncrowded
ditto with podcasting relatively
uncrowded easily to differentiate myself
and to establish a podcast that would
stand out from the crowd and be appeal
to my audience and the ability to become
the signal above the noise was very very
high and as it stands right now
podcasting has become much more
crowded and I think that it is something
I would not pursue with the same degree
of conviction or at least it wouldn't
seem Obvious off the bat this is a
question from Chris how is cutting back
on booze going any advice on how to set
expectations with friends who are
particularly fond of drinking um cutting
back and booze is going uh really well I
haven't had any in I don't know a week
or two and I'm planning on doing no
booze for all of October and the first
half of November so it'll be minimum of
six weeks with no booze whatsoever and
in terms of setting
expectations it's it's I would say
number one being up front if I'm ever
invited to go out that I'm not drinking
and I don't want to have a big
conversation about it I don't want to
feel pressured I am just not drinking
right now and you could use a an
athletic goal as a pretext for that say
you're trying to cut down on weight say
you're trying to see how it affects your
HRV you could certainly use anything
like that you could say that you're
taking medication or supplements that
might be contraindicated with alcohol
which is pretty much everything by the
way way so it doesn't need to be a lie
it can just be maybe an overemphasized
minor truth in this case so all of those
approaches I think could work pretty
well all right here's a question I get a
lot actually this is from bronislav your
face is so smooth no wrinkles do you use
any particular skin products or have you
had any beauty treatments like botox or
anything like that no I have not had any
of those enhancements
whatsoever and I have
used Dr Broner's
unscented Castile soap so large
containers of Dr Bronner's unscented
soap for pretty much everything for
years now so
I I refill my hand soap with Dr Bronner
and there are these devices you can get
on Amazon with mason jars that help you
to BAS basically create Foams doing this
so you can put that in your bathroom or
anywhere else and that is effectively
all I use for both my face my head and
my body and my general approach with
self-care
is the fewer chemicals the fewer
ingredients the better and this has been
my policy for a long time it's also why
I tend not to use
sunscreens occasionally I'll use
something that is predominantly zinc
oxide if I'm going to be in a very harsh
set of conditions for instance
especially if I'm on snow or anything
that's going to be reflective where I
might get incredibly burned then I might
use something like that but otherwise I
will use long sleeve shirts hats Etc to
minimize my sun exposure or take breaks
right I'll be exposed for 20 to 30
minutes and then I'll take a break and
I'll slowly acclimate over time as
opposed to
putting sunscreen with 30 ingredients on
my skin and we've seen recall after
recall after recall for instance of
sunscreens based on different
carcinogens and so on so not sure that's
helpful but I will say that there is
such a thing
as over
applying chemistry and enhancements to
your body and your face so I really try
to use a light hand and the less the
better I would also say that your
external condition I think
is often a reflection of your internal
condition so I do consume a lot of
healthy fats I take Nordic
Naturals Omega-3 supplements I alternate
between fish and
algae which has completely eliminated
any type of nausea that I have felt from
other omega-3 supplementation as an
example
I pay a lot of attention to diet so I
would say I'm working from the inside
out as opposed to trying to address sort
of the cracks in the veneer with topical
treatments but I get this question a lot
so I wanted to take a stab at answering
it I also think that the the lighting in
the camera are are very flattering at
the moment I do have crows feet large
crows feet
so all right let's see I have question
from big dog do you notice pattern in
your happiness levels in regards to
different types of social activities
parties nightclubs events hiking Etc I
would say definitely I do and uh for
this reason I try to schedule two guys
trips for me so two guys trips per year
at least which are generally in the six
to eight person range doing something
active the last trip was back in side
country skiing I could certainly see
another option being hiking or fishing
or something that involves
movement and group dinners group could
be two or three I think the ideal number
for me is probably 3 to five maybe even
three to six as long as people don't
split off into side conversations
ideally when I am in a city that makes
that easy to organize or a place where
that is easy to organize I would say two
to three times a week seems to be the
magic number but even once per week
honestly
ideally say Wednesday something like
that or during the week which gives me a
say booster shot of well-being from a
mental psycho emotional perspective to
carry me then through the rest of the
week Friday Saturday Sunday Kind of take
care of themselves especially Friday
Saturday so those
are few few things will had a good
answer for the the alcohol and what to
say to your friends I just tell them I'm
allergic to alcohol I break out in
handcuffs when I drink that's pretty
good all right
question we got lots of questions now
okay that's because we have 1,382 people
now instead of
31 oh okay who do you want to interview
you haven't interviewed yet there are so
many people who come to mind Ryan
Reynolds would be very high on my list I
would really love to have him on the
podcast but TBD this is from Hungarian
language and culture have you ever
thought about interviewing Dan John I
have thought about interviewing Dan John
and thank you for the reminder so I'm
going to write that down I am a big fan
of Dan John and easy strength and his
work with pav Tulin
and certainly he would be an interesting
addition to the roster so I will put
that down this is from PJ where in your
creative process do you feel the
greatest friction today and what
strategies from the top 1% of creatives
you've interviewed have worked for you
to help overcome them so I would say the
friction honestly is
feeling fear around delving into new
formats that could be screenplay it
could be comic book writing uh which I
think is the most likely next step for
me I think comics and I have the DC
Comics guide to writing Comics something
along those lines let me grab it the DC
Comics guide to writing Comics right
here by Dennis O'Neal which is a great
book by the
way and the challenge for me is getting
started it's also delivering
something by a specific deadline so in
terms
of the top 1% creatives and and what I
have borrowed or find useful that I
think could help me get over this hump
frankly it's being accountable to other
people so I've brought in others to help
me with creative concept art pushes and
I'm in the process of reviewing various
types of environmentals and backgrounds
for instance right now and there are
deadlines for
that that helps push the ball forward
with something like the comics I think
having if for instance an accountability
partner or a coach to focus on things
like this so that if I do not deliver
it's a matter of very uncomfortable
conversation where they say Tim you
committed to doing this by this point in
time you didn't do it you've hired me to
help you with accomplishing these
things what are we doing here one of the
questions I get a lot is when you're
getting this advice from four or five
people per
month what do you pay ATT attention to
do you a fomo about doing certain things
and not other things how do you
incorporate all the advice and frankly
there are times when I experiment with
new types of advice and then there are
times when I hit pause and I say if I
were to assume I know what to do what
are the things I know I should do what
are the things I know work cold exposure
resistance
training very basic meditation 20
minutes twice a day there are certain
ingredients that are easy to neglect
because they don't have the newness they
aren't the shiny objects that have been
put in front of me by a guest who I
admire and aspire to be more like right
so often times it's not a question of
figuring out what to add
it's rather a question of looking very
closely at why you are are failing to
implement the few things that you know
reliably work and then removing those
impediments so all right you have
resistance there are certain obstacles
or things that are preventing you
from re-engaging with these things
you're doing them consistently what are
those how can you make them automatic
how can you look at the work of say BJ
fog
and perhaps James clear right Atomic
habits so that you can build these
things into automatic behaviors like
brushing your
teeth
and those are phases that alternate for
me right now I'd say I am not in the new
habit accumulation phase but rather
looking back over my experience over the
last 5 to 10 years what are the things
that consistently work that work almost
every time I Implement them consistently
and how can I return to those things all
right couple of other questions yitu I
apologize if I'm not pronouncing that
correctly have you ever learned about or
studied the talmud I haven't directly
I'm very interested I'm interested in in
holy scriptures
overall and I'm actually going to be
taking time over the next month to to
read a lot of these these holy
scriptures I think that it is probably
impossible to
understand Humanity as it has evolved or
changed over certainly the last 2,000
years 3,000 years without depending on
Whose scriptures we're referring to
without having some at least basic
passing familiarity with these texts so
I will be taking that time over the next
three to four
weeks here's a question from David this
is about language learning Tim you've
talked and written so much about
language learning but not as much about
maintaining and revamping your languages
I'm trilingual in working on language
number four thanks in no small part to
resources like the 4our chef and feel
that keeping up with all my languages is
often just as much work as acquiring
them in the first place what practices
or processes if any do you have for
keeping up with your Japanese Spanish
and other languages all right I do have
some approaches here so number one is
something that's become much easier in
the last handful of years and that is
movies watch movies not only watch say
for instance movies in Japanese so
Japanese movies with English subtitles
watch English language movies with
Japanese subtitles and ditto for Spanish
right so watch English language movies
you know well ideally right could be
something you've seen a hundred times
like die hard or whatever doesn't really
matter with Spanish subtitles and
then conversely watch Spanish language
movies with English subtitles preferably
that's
something that is say a series or a
television show I just find there's a
little bit more Grist for the M and you
can get used to the speech patterns of
various protagonists and actors within a
given Series so I've done that with
Spanish multiple
times another approach is linking them
together so linking languages together
and what I mean by that is if for
instance you have learned in my case
Japanese first when I wanted to
learn German I bought
both Japanese language versions of One
Piece which is a very famous manga very
famous comic book I bought German
language versions of this same one piece
comic book which is a global phenomenon
many people know it now but certainly
back in
2005 this would have been less
common in German and then later in
Spanish so I could read the same series
and if I'm reading the German and and I
don't understand a section rather than
going to an an English German dictionary
or a German English dictionary I'm going
back to the Japanese and I'm using the
Japanese to learn the meaning of the
German and by doing that I'm reviewing
my Japanese while acquiring the German
and then later for instance when I did
Spanish I used the
German language version of One Piece as
my safety net for the Spanish language
version of one piece so I'm reading it
in Spanish if I don't understand
something I'm not going to English I'm
not going to Japanese I'm going to my
most recent language which is going to
be in that case German if that makes any
sense and what's beautiful about these
comic books is they are laid out Page by
Page Pain by
pain typically in exactly the same way
uh so the dialogue should map really
cleanly and another benefit which I just
alluded to for the comic books is that
they are almost entirely dialogue rather
than
Exposition dense Pros that is very
literary in nature almost all of it is
dialogue and granted they might be
talking about Pirates or something else
that's not going to fall into your daily
conversation all the time but a lot of
it will and certainly the grammar will
all right that is language learning this
is a question from Krishna Molly pup
it's mollypop
right there my dog can you please share
more on your daily care and routine for
Molly we have puppy and want to
incorporate best practices and diet plan
training big thanks for everything you
do thanks for the question uh so I do
have some videos on YouTube related to
basics of dog training I am not the
world's greatest dog trainer but I did
spend a lot of time looking at different
types of training as far as books go I
would strongly recommend don't shoot the
dog by I believe it's Karen prior who
popularized clicker training using
clicker training which she had initially
I believe refined with aquatic mammals
who really don't respond to negative
reinforcement right if you're training a
dolphin and they don't do what you want
them to do you can't really fold up a
newspaper and smack the dolphin on the
butt with bad dolphin they just swim
away so you you then in turn get much
better at positive reinforcement this is
also true if you're say trying to train
a chicken which is something I still
want to learn how to
do I want to do a weekend course in
training chickens and one of the quotes
in the book I remember I can't remember
the attribution but it was no one should
be allowed to have a child until they've
been forced to train a chicken and
there's a lot to it so if you want to
learn about conditioning overall and
certainly as it relates to a dog I think
clicker training and Karen prior and
don't shoot the dog are a great place to
start uh there are some fantastic ftic
YouTube channels uh which I believe at
least last I checked I referred to in
the description and some of my videos on
the Tim Ferris YouTube channel so you
can take a look at those but there are
various types or categories of training
there's safety which should take
precedence over say kind of vanity
tricks right dog spinning around less
important than the dog staying say in
the back of the car and not jumping out
until you've issued a command that sort
of releases the dog jump out because
they could get hit by passing car or
something like that in terms of
routines lots and lots of walking Breed
by breed different breeds will have
higher demands if they're working dogs
like a border or collie you really
shouldn't have that dog in an apartment
in the city for instance they just
require way too much exercise for it to
be compatible with most people in a
heavily Urban environment but big dogs
really big dogs and really little dogs
do pretty well in those constraint
environments Molly is kind of like her
old man
me former athlete not great endurance
very heat and tolerant so her enthusiasm
outstrips her capacity for work which is
great for me because I can take her for
an hour long or two hour long walk
and I can either do that in the
wilderness or do it leashed usually
attached around the waist and and listen
to an audio book if that's something
that I want to do but I just swam laps
in the pool before jumping onto this Q&A
in freezing cold water as a way to wake
up and that is one of her favorite
activities and she'll run around the
pool from end to end and and basically
doing a shuttle Run for the entire time
that I'm swimming so a tired dog is a
happy dog it's also true for humans by
the way like a physically exhausted
human is generally a happy human and a
well-trained dog is a happy dog dog now
well-trained could be substituted with a
dog with clear rules is a happy dog and
I think that also applies to Parenting
and kids right how consistent are you
how predictable are you and therefore
perceived as stable I think all of these
things apply so those are a couple of
recommendations but certainly when you
look at Karen prior and clicker training
I also think if your puppy is young
enough crate training is one of the
greatest gifts you can give your dog
do not give your puppy the opportunity
to make mistakes it's harder to remove
behaviors than it is to prevent them in
the first place so if you don't want
your dog to chew on shoes just get shoes
out of their range get them off of the
floor so they don't develop that habit
and they get past that teething phase
and then you will never have a problem
with your dog chewing shoes here's one
Mary do you batch cook yeah I do what
especially if I'm by myself I'll batch
cook and then I'll eat meals for a while
so I have been following the Slow Carb
Diet as described in the 4our body you
can find it online if you just search
how to lose 100 lbs following the Slow
Carb Diet there's a blog post that I
wrote that lays out all the basics and
you you don't need the book for
that I've been cooking for instance
chili I have chili in the refrigerator
then I cooked up some
955 so 95% ground venison 5% ground
organs Maui Nei venison round meat which
is the most nutritionally dense meat you
can buy in the United States as far as
I'm concerned and they have the analysis
on the website to to demonstrate just
how how incredibly nutrient
Rich their meat is and their Blends
especially with a bit of organ meat so
I'll cook that and the combination of
that plus the chili plus the little goat
cheese CU you got to have a little goat
cheese Plus plus some sauteed spinach
which was cooked at the same time
that'll feed me for three or four meals
and as someone who's currently flying
solo I'm I'm about to leave the
country that is a fantastic go-to meal
that I can just recycle over and over
again so I I'll I'll generally I would
say
cook batch cook enough to feed me for
four to five meals and then I'll go out
at least once a day to have the social
interaction this is from Leif Leif are
there any Global or national Trends in
the next 5 to 10 years that aren't
talked about enough or you believe more
people should be paying attention to if
applicable how are you personally
preparing for this or these
shifts I would say one that comes to
mind is for lack of a better term
digital emotional surrogacy I'm sure
there is a sexier or more elegant term
for this
but
the
inevitable development that we will have
I would say within the
next probably two
years photorealistic avatars that we can
interact with through say virtual
reality and if you haven't seen the demo
of the meta metaverse with Zucker
with Lex fredman on his recent podcast
on YouTube that showcases what this can
look like I would encourage everybody to
at least watch the first five minutes to
get a taste of things to come with the
ability to interact with photorealistic
avatars Furthermore with the ability to
interact with photorealistic avatars who
might be your favorite celebrity like a
Taylor Swift with very convincing facial
expressions we are getting to a point or
companies like replica for instance
replica with a k at the end Ka instead
of CA where digital companions are going
to become for many people not just a
supplement to human interaction but a
replacement for human interaction so I
would say
that the loneliness
epidemic from my perspective is probably
only going to get more nuance more
complex and
more challenging to address in some
respects because especially for people
like myself or introverts I'm taking
active steps so I'll answer that second
part of your question
to maybe preemptively gir myself for
this but for those people who are
already intimidated or taxed by going
out and interacting with one person or
groups of people you could see the case
for many of them opting out completely
and I think we already have problems
with declining birth rates and there are
many countries that are below
replacement rates at this point so I am
very curious to see what societal impact
that will have the way I am
counteracting that for myself is booking
things on the calendar in advance and by
by in advance I mean at this point I'm
probably six months out booking trips
booking time with friends booking time
with family getting it on the calendar
putting money behind it doesn't have to
be a lot of money but enough money that
you can benefit from the sunk cost
fallacy and feel invested so you won't
cancel things and really giving myself
very few options for opting out of
social encounters I know social
interactions that I've proven to myself
over time are always in my best interest
even if I will drag my feet to get there
in the first place I will leave being
better off so those are uh a few
thoughts in terms of Trends people are
paying a lot of attention to say Ai and
Broad
Strokes or machine learning in Broad
strokes but my interest and certainly
what I'm also watching in my audience
are are some of the societal
implications and the psychological sort
of mass psychological imp of these
things so you will be able to take steps
to perhaps put a moat around yourself to
minimize the damage but this is
something to pay attention to and I
would also say that as these tools
become more and more convincing we've
Blown Away the Turing test it's already
been beaten or passed so as these tools
and machines become more and more
convincing more and more appealing
I think that there will be the very
natural impulse to offload more and more
of the things that we currently handle
in our own heads or manually and if you
want to preserve some of those abilities
you're going to have to decide to be
perhaps a selective leite or at least
for periods of time be a selective leite
how many people here would say their
parents are better at directions offline
not using Google Maps than the younger
generations and I would imagine a lot of
people would raise their hand and this
is perhaps not controversial because
people have decided to embrace something
like Google Maps or many other
competitors to help them with
convenience and accuracy and so on
however if you don't use it you lose it
and it's
easy to embrace
convenience and not recog
severe atrophy of capabilities until
it's very hard to reverse
so I think that that is a meta
awareness that needs to be developed as
we are interacting with these
increasingly seductive and Powerful
tools so long answer but these are
things that I think about all right
here's a question from Andre I will go
on a longer trip to Japan next year and
I would love to know one of your
favorite secret spots in the country for
a visit all right here are a couple
recommendations and uh one will be not
so secret but a lot of foreigners don't
visit it and that's the jibli museum
they call it mitaka Forest but it is
basically in youo kashida park inash
coing you can get the tickets or at
least you could at Lawson convenience
stores you could ask hotel coners to
also try to help you with this I believe
there are now two locations so jibli is
ghib B Li it is effectively the Disney
of Japan Miyazaki ha is the the Figure
Head behind jibli and my favorite movie
Spirited Away is I think they crowning
achievement but I am biased jibli Museum
and Eno kushia Park is also tremendous I
would say if you
drink gen Yamamoto so geen Yamamoto gen
Yamamoto is this tiny tiny I think it
seats six to eight people bespoke
cocktail bar where you sit down and it's
basically om and the bartender serves
you drinks you don't get to request
things you don't get to object you just
get served like a master sushi chef
would put things in front of you various
drinks and you have this experience
which is tremendous and I actually first
met I think it's ging or Yamamoto anyway
at brush stroke I think was the the name
of the restaurant in New York City where
I bumped into him at the time I was
doing the food Marathon from 4-Hour Chef
for those people who remember that where
I had whatever it was 26.2 dishes in 24
hours walking around New York City and
he was sitting there with this ice pick
and a number of tools chiseling huge
blocks of ice into perfect spheres to
make his cocktails and we struck up a
conversation and so when a friend of
mine invited me to this place in Tokyo
I was sitting there and after the first
or second drink we both looked at each
other at the same time and we're like I
know you I know you where do I know you
from and we put put it together so
there's that I would say there is a
semi-underground whiskey bar that is
quite well known in N up in the north so
if you go skiing I would certainly take
a minute and check that out there can't
be too many of them and it's a husband
and wife team the husband is Japanese
and the wife is
I want to say Australian or British I
apologize to her that I'm I'm probably
not getting it right it should be pretty
easy to spot and then if you can get to
ni so NL ni kko in the fall especially
but higher elevation beautiful rural
area if you can get there it's amazing
for sightseeing but they also have
occasional demonstrations of Japanese
horseback archery which is
yabusame um
y a bu u s a m e and if you have the
chance to see that you should definitely
see it it will blow your mind all right
question from Jane at one point you
talked about making the Improvement of
Education in our country a focus is that
still an interest of yours and if so
what are your thoughts at this time
about how to do that yes it's still of
Interest I did shift my focus to mental
health Therapeutics including
psychedelics for the last let's let call
it eight years but education is always
close to the front of my mind and I
would say that I've shifted my focus in
that Arena to not necessarily trying to
fix policy and so on because it's beyond
my capabilities and above my pay grade
it's it's just not the arena where I can
make the most impact by focusing on
Talent sourcing because there there are
often huge surpluses
of scholar ships and funds that are made
available by giant foundations but go
unclaimed because it is challenging in
time to find the most promising
underresourced kids in the country
period it's a talent sourcing problem so
there are organizations like
questbridge which I've supported a lot
in the past and feel very strongly about
there are others that do a lot of good
in public
schools with various core materials and
so on like donors choose.org which I've
been involved with as well and then
there are new startups that are doing
very interesting things with accelerated
learning and harnessing technology for
that purpose certainly KH Academy is
interesting mava is a very new startup
that I have backed and fingers cross
that they do a lot in that field there's
a question from Andy uh Arthur C Brooks
episode had an immediate impact upon my
life philosophies was curious whether it
did the same for you if it had a big
impact you two seem to become fast
friends thanks yes the episode with
Arthur was a real delight and I
appreciated his ability to spin many
plates very well so he is from a secular
perspective very dedicated to studying
the science mostly on the social science
side but certainly tries
to tie that together with Neuroscience
in the fields that he's exploring he is
deeply religious and I find that very
interesting and I
think the question of how to create
meaning more so than Find meaning but
you could use both how to create meaning
in a world of pessimism and nihilism
where in many
countries religion has fallen away at
least in some of the more urban
environments is going to become an
increasingly pressing question uh so I
am personally focused on that for me
individually but also as I just look at
the
different state changes in various
demographics in my my audience it's very
concerning so I I do think about this a
lot and I predicted a few years ago and
we're already seeing this but it will
continue to be the case and will
accelerate dramatic I think there will
be an explosion of what you might
consider new
religions some of them will masquerade
as other things right CrossFit veganism
uh whatever it might be
but very strongly held belief
systems that are defended with religious
fervor where people who are Heretics
from within are certainly
ostracized these types of groups some of
them with overt spiritual
overtones or laws slash Commandments
slash intentional living rules whatever
you might call it but I think we will
see a vast proliferation of these things
as well as more uptake with the sort of
judeo Christian or abrahamic religions I
think all of those things are going to
become more and more appealing to humans
who love it or hate it seem to be
inextricably combined with religion or
the seeking of this thing called
God and it's even in the most secular of
societies people worship something and I
think the people who are at most risk of
self-deception and societal problems are
those people who aren't clear on what
they're
worshiping and this is borrowing
from I think it might have been an
infinite Gest but everyone worships
something so it's just a question of
knowing what you're worshiping so so
that has certainly become of Greater
interest to me this is a question from
Rees weightlifting for longevity what
are your thoughts what are you doing
differently I think if you're going
to choose one type of exercise and one
type of exercise only resistance
training which can sometimes take the
form often takes the form of weight
training would be the best investment
for longevity and health span certainly
for combating age related decline of
muscle mass and so on and so forth there
were a lot of
questions that have come up in the Pres
submitted questions around say the Slow
Carb Diet weight loss how do you make
weight loss sustainable and a lot of
people have the experience of losing
weight and then regaining that weight
and uh for instance I'm helping my dad
right now with slow carb diet in the
last I want to say three months he's
lost 53 lbs so he's doing really
well those gains meaning those losses
are hard to hold on to unless you
upgrade your underlying machinery and
what I mean by that is increasing muscle
mass sort of
your
mitochondrial engine so to speak such
that you have greater ability to dispose
of glucose right you have better ability
with this enhanced Machinery to generate
heat
to manage your insulin and glucose
response to food so weight training
really we could look at the sort of
mortality rates associated with broken
hips and so on in elderly
populations there's so many
different outputs from in the one lever
of consistent progressive resistance
with say weight training that for me
it's just it's just a no-brainer yes
there are other things that you can do
and should do probably like zone two
training is described by petera
but for me if based on all of the data
based on certainly surveying my audience
seeing what works what doesn't who's
able to keep weight off who's able to
sustain their progress over time the
common factor that I've identified is
weight
training now why do I say weight
training yes I said resistance training
because you can use something like gymn
gymnastic strength training GST which is
fantastic but it is in some cases more
challenging to quantify the progress
whereas if you're lifting dumbbells 10
pounds is 10 pound 12 lb is 12 lb 15 lb
is 15 lb and you such a case it's it's
really basic and very straightforward to
track your progressive resistance where
you're increasing the amount of weight
or the number of reps
and increasing the productive stress
that you are applying to your system
over time and I should note that that is
another reason why if you have proper
instruction very very key underline
underline if you have proper technical
instruction that free weights are often
Superior to machines if you're in one
place and you always will have access to
the same machines feel free to use
machines but otherwise in my case when I
am traveling a lot of the
Year dumbbells are for instance barbells
are easy to use anywhere I find them and
a pound is a pound or a kilogram is a
kilogram so that's a long answer to a
short question but uh if I had to pick
one tool for longevity in the exercise
bucket not on the diet side of things or
in other categories I would choose for
myself weight training this is a
question from Natalie hey Tim what have
you learned from years of interviewing
around asking the right questions and
enabling meaningful conversations so I
would say I've learned a whole bunch and
I'll probably do a a
recap if such a thing is possible around
the 10y year anniversary of the podcast
because I feel like I've learned a lot
in terms of asking questions I would say
that an interview is very much like a
conversation if you meet someone at a
cocktail party and your first or second
question is tell me about the most
traumatic experience of your life
they're going to think you're a crazy
person because nobody communicates that
way and there is a rapport
building feeling out process so I plan
for that and I often will spend say 10
minutes 5 to 10 minutes before we record
having a conversation so that the guest
can feel more at ease with me so that we
can then get into some other
corners and I will also set the
expectation in advance that they have
Final Cut they have final edit they will
get a transcript they can remove
anything they want to remove I will also
look out for them and for that reason we
should really
explore the edges we should really push
and let it fly why
because I can always cut things out
later but we can't add the interesting
or the unexpected back in later so that
effectively buys both of us permission
to go places that might not be typical
for a conversation I always tell them
where I'm going to start so they build
confidence in the beginning and no one
stumbles out of the gates and I also I
would say look for the side alleys
realizing that my podcast is not live
for instance sometimes the digressions
don't work sometimes the the exit ramp
that I think could take us somewhere
interesting don't work but other times
they really end up being incredibly
important and one example that hops to
mind is my conversation with Debbie
milman my first interview of Debbie
milman and some of you will recognize
that name also because she and I had a
conversation around childhood abuse and
our respective healing
Journeys from early childhood abuse and
the reason I felt comfortable going
there with her personally right for my
own story was that when I first
interviewed her the list of questions
all the prep was intended to focus
on her background in graphic design and
her career
trajectory but I had noticed that
whenever she was asked about her
childhood or her parents she would
generally answer in one or two
very vague General statements and move
on and I thought that was curious and I
wanted to learn more about it I didn't
suspect what was coming but I felt like
at least we could cover some new
territory and I asked her if she would
be comfortable this is part of my 5 to
10 minutes before we hit record with me
asking her about her childhood and she
said well maybe we'll see you can try
and then I'll answer if I feel
comfortable and I asked her about this
and this was pretty early in the
conversation ation I would say in the
first half hour and it ended up being
the first time she had ever spoken
publicly about childhood sexual abuse
and this incredibly traumatic period in
her life and everything she' done to try
to recover from that and that was the
rest of the interview right so I
always try to take a shot at
the at the odd question or topic maybe
it comes up in my research maybe it
comes up in the conversation where
there's a throwaway comment that might
not be a throwaway comment and then I
ask well let's come back to that for a
second you know how did that make you
feel some very basic follow-up questions
often do the
trick what did you learn from
that walk us through that moment you
know what was your internal experience
what was your selft talk when a happened
or when you did be these very basic
follow-up questions that take you off
script often lead to the most fertile
ground and also in the first I would say
10 minutes or so I try to ask questions
that they have never been asked
before simply to show based on my
research with say some very Arcane point
in Wikipedia that links to another thing
that links to another reference that
links to another reference and I get a
quote from I'm making this up but the
second boss they ever had when they were
working at an ice cream shop and I ask
them what their interaction was like
with so and so or who was so and so and
how did they fit into your life and they
go oh wow okay you really do your
homework and that snaps them out of any
autopilot dream state that they might
have accidentally slipped into or
deliberately slipped into people who get
interviewed a lot have their 60 minutes
set just like professional comedians
because they learn what works and I
don't blame them I can do the same thing
so those are a few thoughts on things I
I've learned about interviewing I could
go on and on and on but those are a
handful that come to mind this is from
Lexi 30 G within 30 minutes Allah the
slow carb diet or intermittent fasting
I'm still 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes but I will say that that doesn't
mean an entire meal necessarily so I've
been waking up in the mornings for
instance I'll show you what I've been
having I'm going to sound like a bit of
a broken record here
but these
are venison sticks peppered and they
have between 9 and 11 grams of protein
each this is with 100% wild harvested
venison from Maui Nei like Maui as in
the island Nei nuui and full disclosure
I mean I ended up loving these guys so
much that I invested in the company but
that is not why I consume this three of
these I can stick them in a backpack
that's my 30 G and I will have these
first thing in in the morning then go
for a walk with Molly for about a half
hour that's when I will have my first
caffeine I will sit down with the F
minute Journal which is something I have
reintegrated into my
life referring back to what I mentioned
earlier about taking the things that
work and reapplying them ensuring you
are doing them as opposed to constantly
adding the new the new the new so three
of these sticks go for a walk for half
hour have my first caffeine sit down 5
minute Journal get up half hour back and
then by that point I will probably have
some type of small meal this will likely
be around 10:00 a.m. let's say maybe a
little bit earlier and then I'll
postpone that's probably on the order of
400 calories to 500 calories and then I
will have my first real meal per se as
lunch let's call it at 1 p.m. something
like that but I have just seen better
results for people with 30 grams within
30 minutes of waking up it's very
straightforward it's very clear there's
no gray
area and it seems to Kickstart the
metabolic Machinery in a way that is
very helpful for cognition for sustained
energy for a million different things
and there
are if you follow the letter of the law
per se very few ways you can screw that
up with intermittent fasting there are a
lot of ways you can screw that up and we
don't have to get into all the ways
there are many people who thrive on
intermittent fasting but there are a lot
of ways you can screw it up
and if you look at for instance what I
wrote in the 4our chef and the 4our body
but especially in the 4our chef as it
related to accelerated learning failure
points identifying the failure points
and removing as many failure points as
possible 30 grams within 30 minutes of
waking up avoids dozen of different
possible dietary failure points and body
recomposition failure points as well if
you're trying to maintain muscle mass
and decrease your fat mass then I simply
find this to be more consistent for more
people in what I've seen this is from a
drummer what's your approach for
managing fear of death I loved your
practical thoughts on suicide article
from years ago it help me through some
tough times thank you you're very
welcome yeah if people have not read
that if you're in a dark place certainly
call a hotline a suicide hotline if you
need to but I do have a blog post about
my darkest period called some practical
thoughts on suicide if anyone might find
that helpful right now in terms of
managing fear of
death I think that my fear I need to
manage is not fear of death it's fear of
The Descent to death so losing
my health span my cogn ni my physical
performance and I haven't really figured
that out fully to be honest and maybe I
never will but in terms of fear of death
I find stoicism very very helpful and
show you an oldie here this is
literally again hearkening back
to rereading or reintegrating the things
that have worked this is a book from the
Harvard Classics with Plato and pus and
Marcus
aelius I would say senica certainly is a
fantastic addition in terms of MTO Mori
remembering you are going to
die I find and I'm not recommending this
to all people at all but if you have
what would be described as mystical
experiences and you can in a sense
assess these things with questionnaires
as they have done at John's Hopkins and
so on with uh psybin assisted
therapies when you have these
Transcendent experiences where your ego
seems to dissolve that could be through
psychedelics it could be through any
number of different spiritual traditions
and practices Could Happen spontaneously
could happen in meditation and it often
does in experienced meditators or in
some people the very first time they try
a new type of meditation they will have
this experience of Vanishing having the
self vanish for a brief period of time
that was my experience the very first
time I did Transcendental Meditation and
then I spent the next 10 plus years
trying to get back to that state which
turns out to be pretty common but once
you've tasted that for me at least it
begs the
question is that so different from
lights out right is it possible to then
also be the Observer even when the self
is
extinguished is it possible to
experience what we consider
Consciousness even without any identity
to point to and I think the answer is
yes right
also as noval rant I guess has said
before he's like you remember what it
was like before you were born it's like
yeah like that so since sitting here
right now I can't say I was terrified
before I was
born maybe it is very much the same and
of course there are infinite
possibilities and every tradition we can
imagine has come up with some working
theory of what happens in the
afterlife but for better for worse that
is our sense as humans is to be aware of
mortality but those are a few things
that I have found helpful myself all
right very kind words in the comments
thank you guys I really enjoy doing this
I'm I'm thrilled that I get to do it and
really appreciate you all being here all
right this is from Carlos what exercises
techniques work to get rid of your back
pain after the podcast episodes with
Shirley sarman PT PhD there are a number
of things that have been very helpful
I'm still working on it is the short
answer but there are some portable
traction devices that I found quite
helpful let me grab it it's right next
to me so I have been going to a sports
Doctor Who uses a very sophisticated
traction device but I travel so much I
don't always have access to this so this
right here is called Fisher traction and
it basically wraps around a door handle
and then goes around your waist and you
lay on your back and Scoot yourself away
to apply traction and then you relieve
the traction every five minutes or so
and you do repetitions of this I just
listen to an audiobook or hop on the
phone and do that I found that
incredibly helpful for gapping a bit
especially on my my low back right side
say between L4 L5 where I have some
stenosis and nerve impingement because
of a bulging
disc I have found focusing on internal
rotation and external rotation very
helpful that's something that surely
underscored for
me definitely focusing on Terminal hip
extension when walking so ensuring that
I am pushing off of my toe in other
words ensuring that I am pushing off and
getting that last bit of the stride as
opposed to pulling my leg forward with
the hip flexor instead of pulling it
Forward stomp Pull It Forward stomp I'm
trying to push off and make sure I feel
that in my toe on each foot and then
have that leg swing
through and on top of
that there are any number of different
things I could I could add to this of
course but foam rolling the per foris
and the it T bands and tfl I found
incredibly helpful I use a hyper ice
vibrating foam roller which seems to
relieve spasms much more effectively
than other things and then avoiding
certain things so if I sit on a very
hard wooden chair my ql my quadrus
lumborum and external obliques and so on
will spasm to try to support that area
because of the compression sensitivity
so I just have a small pillow that I
throw in my car so if I go to restaurant
I'll just bring that in sounds
ridiculous but for right now it really
really helps also having proper chair
ergonomics setup so even at this kitchen
table where I'm doing this recording
right now I'm sitting in an airon chair
with lumbar support with some foot
elevation on the floor so that I have
support instead of say leaning forward
on my elbows the whole time and
fidgeting back and forth in such a way
that causes those stabilizing muscles to
light up and then ultim
spasm hopefully that is helpful and yes
to everyone who's asking I have read the
Sarno books I'm going to reread them but
not all back pain is emotional or
psychological some of it is absolutely
I'm going to reread these things the
last year of my life has been incredibly
stressful from a relationship
perspective especially having a 5-year
relationship and roughly one year ago
and all of the shifting Sands that have
come about after that has been very very
challenging and I think I doubled down
on a lot as a way to occupy myself to
weather that storm which I don't
actually view as a bad coping strategy
but it wouldn't surprise me if there are
emotional components and I have very
clear structural biomechanical issues
that also have some explanatory power
and I do know doctors including the the
sports doctor I referred to earlier who
were very close with Sarno and
constantly debated with him about these
types of thing if somebody gets in a car
accident suddenly they have back pain
they never had before maybe it's the car
accident and not just their emotional
response to the car accident and it's
kind of insulting to the patient I think
to always insist that it is in their
head per se
right at the same time I would say that
pain perception of pain pain patterning
and psycho emotional health and the
stories we tell ourselves are seemingly
very intertwined so I I don't want to
dismiss that and a lot of pain I think
can be at least partially explained with
a lot of what Saro describes all right
take a look at a few more and then I got
to go because I'm actually uh talking
about back pain I'm going to a pilates
class and for those people who poo poo
Pilates if you work with someone who is
very very very very
technical and they're very good at
addressing the core maintaining proper
pelvis
position it makes everything better I'm
just going to say it makes everything
everything better and that goes for top
athletes as well even if I were at the
peak of my competitive Powers one of the
things I would have said to myself 30
years ago was do Pilates two or three
times a week it is going to check a lot
of boxes and cover a lot of bases you
are not covering and it will
minimize the likelihood of chronic pain
and injury
later a lot of people ask me for dating
advice I don't think I'm in a position
to give dating
advice I'm not bad at dating I'm
actually good at it
but ask somebody who' you know dated
around and then met the love of their
life now they have three kids and have
got all that [__] figured out you
know it's like don't don't go to the
morbidly obese guy and ask him how to
lose weight I mean I'm not saying that's
who I am equivalent wise in the
relationship realm but like the proof is
in the pudding so I I would say maybe
listen to Arthur C Brooks and other
folks on that more although I I will say
that in this Modern Age it is uniquely
bizarre to date with digital tools and
apps and also all of the social dynamics
at play especially in the United States
it is
[__] insane so there is that
but I am not overly concerned about it I
will figure it out my favorite movie of
the last two years you know I'm thinking
about re-watching actually one of my
favorites two Spirited Away which I
mentioned already and then also a
prophet or un profet it's a French film
I won't ruin it by telling you anything
about the story but it is beautifully
shot also quite brutal but it is a
Heroes Journey par exit
all in a very modern setting so people
can check that out if they would like to
check it out all right let me take a
look at a few more things this is a pres
submitted question from Chris what is
one book you love that was better the
second time around and why there are
there are many but I would say that on
writing by Stephen King you really can't
read about fiction until you've tried
some fiction so once I tried my hand at
more fiction in the form of the legend
of [__] punch if you guys have no idea
what that is you can Google it then it
meant a lot more to read say Ann
Lamont's writing or the writing of other
writers on the craft of fiction also the
moral letters to lucilius the letters of
Sena if you want to find those for free
you can just search the tow of Sena and
I put together a bunch of PDFs with
fantastic artwork and calligraphy and so
on because there's a lot of overlap in
in the the stoic and Buddhist
philosophies and belief
systems and I wanted to highlight that
so if you if you just Google to of Sena
you will find a bunch of PDFs for free
and I think that is it guys let me just
take a quick look see if there's
anything else of course as usual more
questions than I can possibly
answer here's one more from Shelby how
do you break negative selft talk I would
say gratitude practice easy way to
embrace that is using something like the
five-minute journal and DBT dialectic
behavioral therapy I think is
undervalued underutilized and very
impressively systematized in a way that
lends it to scientific study which is
incredibly rare and impressive in a
world where psychiatric tools are
notoriously squishy and hard to evaluate
so DBT would also be on the short list
and I would say if you wanted something
that is very graspable the work by Byron
Katie and turnarounds she has worksheets
available for free online is incredibly
incredibly helpful continues to be
helpful for me personally as well all
right guys I'm going to go do some
exercise I encourage everyone to do the
same and I appreciate you all tuning in
hopefully this was helpful and uh I
recognize that a lot of people are
feeling the the Spectre of
uncertainty Doom scrolling certainly
does nothing but pour gasoline on the
fire of fear and doubt so monitor your
information intake consider a low
information diet and and recognize as
well as evidenced by the live chat here
and a lot of the patterns in the live
chat You Are Not Alone every human is
uniquely endowed with superpowers and
super weaknesses and everyone is
fighting a battle fighting struggles
that you know nothing about so rest
assured that you are not alone in
experiencing those things
so kakaha I would say stay strong and I
will talk to you guys soon thanks for
tuning in
guys